parents expected to spend more on back  to school supply shopping this year  the national retail federation expects  parents to spend an average of 268  dollars per child  that's a nine percent increase from last  year and well we may remember that last  year's big sellers were  computers and tablets as students geared  up for the online learning and distance  learning education  so this year itself return back to  traditional clothes and  school supplies and of course don't  forget our school supply drive that  we're having it's the great a school  supply drive you hear the information  there on your screen we're collecting  all sorts of things  for our valley students drop all the  donations off at any smith's locations  through this thursday